what percentage of women
hate Andrew Tate it's a great question
oh my God I feel like we have to most
women lie right like most women have no
idea about what they're talking about
and they don't understand their own
emotions so I would say like I'd say
like 90 of women say they hate Andrew
Tate but I would actually say 100 of
women are looking for a man like Andrew
Tate that's the reality yeah so how do
you grow up with that cognitive
dissonance I believe is what that's
called oh I'm just used to the cognitive
dissonance what do you mean I mean
everyone's cognitive and crazy cognitive
dissonance everywhere in life these days
okay but what do you what do you mean
don't be intellectually lazy
intellectually lazy you can use it
exactly that's an inside joke there but
go ahead we're gonna say about the
cognitive dissonance no I mean I just
think a lot of women are all in their
emotions you know they say they want one
thing but they really want another and
you know I agree with Andrew when he
says women don't know what they want
right like women think they want a nice
guy
um they don't want a nice guy that end
up walking all over him and
disrespecting him and then they won't
respect him
um so 90 of women May hate Andrew but I
think that 99.9 of women love Andrew
would like a man like Andrew got it
you're doing a lot of head nodding out
of there I don't know if you're
listening to like a DMX album or you're
just a dream with Leia no no I totally
agree so I think majority of American
women are inherently feminists I think
they're born and created that way at
this point in time so I would say yeah
90 of women probably say they hate
Andrew Tate but I kind of feel like if
you put those women in a room one-on-one
with Andrew Tate and he put some moves
on him I think they'd say yes like so
they hate him but I think they sleep
with him so like how much do you really
hate him then but I mean I don't think
women have ever been presented the
option of uh of a man that is like that
attractive and successful for the most
part that's true got it so or what
percentage of women
hate your cousin Andrew Taylor my cousin
well here's the thing the more I
actually like watch his stuff I like I
thought I hated him at first like when I
first saw the first few
clips and then like I see things like he
was like talking about mental illness in
men and saying that like you know that
just keeps them down and there's a way
out you know saying that that's just
your brain you know ends up making them
commit suicide and they can find a way
out of that I'm like okay I agree with
that you know and you know there I saw
something else where he was like well
what if your son was gay would you still
love him he's like absolutely and I'm
like that's great and then I saw
something else where it's like what type
of girls do you pick 18 to 20 you gotta
find them young and so you can mold
their brain and I'm like
so we're into that I but there's but
there's a lot of things that he says
that I do agree with okay I think
sometimes just a little bit more on the
extreme side when it comes to women like
he's putting all women in a certain
right here you know like that's it's not
that's your problem when girls say like
you know all men are bad no not all men
are bad yeah you know just because you
had two or three experiences
I don't like that but like his
intellectual like inside thoughts I
actually agree no doubt the guy's a a
thinker speaker a talker not what
percentage of women hate Andrew Tate I
would say actually I think it's changed
I think before it's been more like 100
of women hate him but I think now after
all of this and everybody's like kind of
forced to listen to like him
um I think the number has maybe gotten
down to maybe like
hopefully like 80 percent of women only
hate him just because like you know like
Sarah said like once you listen to some
of the content and the behind what he's
like saying women do want to get behind
it they're looking for someone like him
maybe not as you know bald and vocal
like he is but essentially they want a
strong man with discipline and you know
who can lead and then do all those
things so I would say today maybe like
80 I'm gonna give us ladies a little
wiggle room so it's going down I think
it's gone I think it's going down based
on everything that's going on well I
think a lot of the reasons why is that
women will judge an entire person on a
30-second Tick Tock clip yeah right so
you'll just rush the judgment on anyone
what seeing one clip oh boom he canceled
uh no I didn't like what he said
I think it's because women are very
emotional right like we are way more
emotional than men like you brought up
that clip with me earlier like that
makes me emotional because I genuinely
like mean what I said for from the heart
yeah and like I think women are more
emotional so like yes if you see a video
of Andrew saying something which is
Harsh and naturally exaggerated for
marketing purposes it's going to trigger
an emotion in you and then I think it
takes um from my experience
um either more time or a man around you
to say hang on Leia like why don't you
look at it from this perspective you
know and you can actually see the logic
and then you're like oh yeah okay
actually that makes sense so I think
women naturally are gonna not like him
because we are emotional yeah I think
I've had some experiences as of late
with women and being a guy with a bar in
South Beach and being out yada yada
um so I had I think I told you this the
other day I'm out with some friends
a buddy of mine he brings some girls
we're out we're having dinner whatever
whatever whatever I try to strike up a
conversation with this girl
um they were in town they're visiting
South Beach and the whole night was just
we all have a great time it was a fun
dinner we all good laughs great boom we
paid for everything you know sent them
home in an Uber treated them well all
good like it couldn't have been a better
experience for these girls is what I'm
saying everyone had a great time my
buddy's dating one of the friends like
the rest of us we all just kind of got
along one of the girls hey let's keep in
touch whatever exchange numbers boom
boom boom boom boom
they left it like two three in the
morning boom we all went and called it a
night that was Friday night I wake up
Saturday morning wake up to the text and
the the text read so you [ __ ] with Tate
that was the text read not hey thanks
for a great night hey appreciate it hey
you know just so you [ __ ] with Tate
that's what I wake up to right so it's 9
A.M whatever I'm like yeah
and I was just like uh I mean yeah I I
interviewed him like he's cool and she's
like you disgust me and I go like excuse
me what do you what did I do she's like
how could you even affiliate with that
person and I said well what don't you
like about him and we go it's a text
exchange I think I told you something
that's right yeah we have this text
exchange and she's just like I just
think he's disgusting and anyone who
listens to him is a disgusting man I go
well
um correct me if I'm wrong how was our
night last night yeah she goes well what
do you mean I go did you have fun yes
did we disrespect you at all no did we
pay for everything yes uh did you enjoy
yourself yes so what are you saying
right now
right and she's just like uh I don't
know just like
you know I just don't like him and I was
like well tell me what you don't like
about him and she's like I just don't
like him and I literally ended the
conversation I go text me when you grow
up and I just that was it that was the
end of the [ __ ] conversation because
the cognitive dissonance that we're
talking about here's a guy and his
friends that just took care of you and
your entire crew all night right food
drinks Ubers just lifestyle Miami South
Beach you didn't pay for [ __ ] we didn't
disrespect you you had a great time and
that's what you wake up and text me
first thing in the morning you were too
nice
because like you you spent way too much
money on this channel not at all like I
don't know I would have it like it's
probably not dropping the bucket okay
like not a big deal it's not like oh I'm
broke now whatever we four guys put a
thousand dollar bill a couple hundreds
literally right it's not a big deal
whatsoever like money ain't the problem
here it's the disrespect and it's the
because of what you did for her right
like you gave her your resources and the
next day she just disrespects you
without even asking and thinking and at
all like you know even giving some
Nuance to who you are and what you did
for her last night right that's the
disrespect because you provided and
immediately she's like you think this
you're a bad person and that's and
that's disrespectful so if you like that
clip click right here to watch another
or if you want to watch the entire
saucecast click right here
[Music]